Hello the internet.
Am in a hole?
I look like I'm shorter.
You're always shorter than me.
I'm always shorter.
I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys,
I almost couldn't remember the name
of our channel for a second.
There's this company called SOG,
or S-O-G, I'm not sure how they say it.
They were like,
"Hey, if we send you knives do you want
to try and cut a bullet off with one?"
and I thought, yeah.
Yeah.
Just reply, yes.
Yes, here's my address.
We're not going to use a real bullet,
we're just going to use
our trusty air pistol
because it's way less dangerous
and I have a very small backyard
where discharging a
firearm would be insanity.
You know we've got a
small back board here.
I think a bullet would
probably go through that.
So we're going to try to cut the pellet,
pop these two balloons.
Reminds me of one of
those 22plinkster videos,
except you're not going to do it
over your shoulder like this.
I'm not going to be like
here firing stuff all over,
I'm just going to be like
right next to the thing
missing it all the time.
We're going to use the 2511 on this one.
Need a fast camera,
need a higher frame rate.
Let's see what happens shall we?
We'll start off by shooting this
in a 28,000 fringe a second in 720p.
And that means the use of the V2511,
which is very loud.
There it is.
What?
I can't hear you, what?
Okay what's your predictions
for how this first shot
is going to go?
As this the first shot,
I might need to get my eye in.
Hone it in?
Yeah remember the candle video we did?
Yeah.
It took a few goes didn't it?
It did.
So I'm thinking this is
going to be something similar
where we have to get it
perfect on the left or right,
but it doesn't matter if
we get it not so perfect
on the up and down.
All right I can get on board with that.
All right I'm going to go.
Have you got your eye protection on?
What?
Eye-pro?
Yeah.
Wow!
I got hit.
Did you?
What with?
Was it a shot?
I don't know, something hit me.
You all right?
Yeah.
I don't know if it was balloon or not.
Bugger.
It was the pellet.
Just a tiny piece of pellet.
Wonder if it was this bouncing back.
It's not very safe is it?
Lovely split, not really a 50/50 split,
but is it two pieces on that one side?
Yeah.
So it split into three?
Yeah I think so.
Popped both balloons,
you see there it's hit the...
Yeah it's coming right back at us.
How's that, wait?
It's made a little chip in the wood,
and it's now just hurdling
back towards my hands.
That looked like it was
going almost into the lens.
Good job it didn't.
Yeah.
I mean, it hit my hand and
it didn't hurt that much,
so it probably would've
just dinged the glass,
but still we need to
rethink our angles here.
Maybe it's just because
the angle of the back stop
perfectly hit it and came back.
What are the chances of that though?
It could have gone anywhere.
Damn good job we were
wearing eye protection.
I did say, "You got
your eye protection on?"
It went right over your head.
Yeah.
Oh--
You all right there?
No.
Why what's going on?
The balloon is like weak at the rim
so it's not like,
you know when you blow into
one normally it holds the rim
and lets you blow into it?
It's weak so I'm like--
It's not letting me blow into it.
To avoid the same thing happening again
where it obviously hit the wood there
and bounced straight back in the camera,
I'm going to try tilting the wood back
because of the angle
it's going to go higher.
Sounds good.
Miss the camera.
Do you want a whole face protection?
Yeah all right I'll go get one.
Good idea.
I've changed the resolution to 512x320
which is teenie weenie,
but we are now at 120,000 frames a second
and I've got a nice, long treenie cable
so I don't get hit again.
I think I missed.
Did you miss the knife?
No I think I hit the side of the knife
and it deflected to the
left and hit the balloon.
Oh all right.
Oh no.
Oh you actually got it.
I did get it.
Oh perfectly, baby.
That was perfect.
So I think the fault
was just in the angle.
The actual shot on the knife--
Oh it's satisfying.
That's perfect as well.
Where did it go?
So it went into the purple one,
didn't pop, it went straight through,
and I think it just missed the green one.
What?
Came out the other side of
the purple one, ripping it.
Wow
Oh man.
It must have missed by such a fine amount
on that green there.
Yeah, very close.
All right let's reset.
Okay.
You know, looking at the footage,
it was like it was almost touching it.
I feel like it looked like
it went directly into it
and just disappeared.
It must have just slightly...
Is that from it?
No, maybe?
Do you think that it
could be from a scrape?
That could be you know,
so see if we traced that,
I can just about see the
knife from this position here.
So it must have just scraped it there.
It just goes past there.
That's so close.
Just for some curiosity here
I've know switched the focus
from being on the front of the blade
to it's now the front of the balloons
because we've seen what happens
when it splits on the blade,
so now we're really just interested
in seeing what happens at this point.
Because on this balloon,
it went in and then popped
the other side of the balloon.
It didn't split from the hole.
It's so weird.
Yeah.
What happened?
Even though it missed that one
what was cool to see about that one
is that you saw the pellet
go through the front,
carry on through the
middle of the balloon,
and it still had enough speed
and there was still enough tension
in the back of the balloon,
that it split through the back too.
So it didn't just get caught
up in the loose rubber,
it was still going fast enough
and this was still stretched
enough for it just to go
see you later.
That really puts it into perspective
how quickly those pellets go.
Yeah.
So by the time it hit
the back of the balloon,
half of the balloon was all ready open,
and it was just pretty much air on air.
Even though the entry was that big
and it still managed to
split at the other side.
That's ridiculous.
It can race through a balloon
quicker than the ballon can pop.
It's fast.
That is fast.
If it was a bullet it'd be even faster.
Because I'm firing
directly down the blade,
it's incredibly difficult to actually see
where the the middle is,
if not impossible.
Because it's so thin.
So if you look directly at
the middle of the blade,
you see that?
Only one side should be purple
then this side should be purple.
Yeah.
See that?
That's why I'm using two different colors
so that I can actually see
the middle of the blade
because other wise I'm basically like,
"Right, directly in between
the yellow and the purple."
Because other wise it
would just all be purple,
I'd be like,
"I don't know what--"
Wow amazing split again.
Oh simultaneous, it's like
identical on both sides.
Perfect symmetry there.
That's a lovely shot.
Thank you, and well done for your shot.
Thank you, Daniel.
We will now get a side on angle
with the green and the yellow.
How about that?
Oh, how about that?
What?
Surprised me for some reason.
No idea why.
It surprised you?
Yeah.
Shooting up ballons?
Bloody hell!
It was loud.
So I've managed to after looking
find half of the pellet I fired.
So it's been completely
split in half by the knife.
As you can see,
the outside of it is
kind of dull and rusty
because I let it get wet and
didn't really look after it.
But if I turn it over,
it's completely shiny and new.
The internal metal.
And it's just been perfectly sliced.
Some nice, very slow shweeny
looking footch there.
Bit of metal on metal.
Satisfying how it just
perfectly sliced it in half.
Yeah.
It's not even managed to dent the knife,
it just sort of stained it.
I think the pellet's just really soft.
Yeah I'm sure if you hit
the pellets against anything
it would mush and split apart,
but because it's such a sharp knife
it's making very clean cuts through it
and leaving you with that
polished edge on the inside.
It's even making the pellets
not perfectly straight,
but the inside's been cut is like,
sort of concave like that
because it's going like
that around the knife,
and then being sent either direction
so it's sort of going...
Very cool.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter.
We've got a channel,
it's this one.
We've got a second channel as well,
it's that one.
Feel free to subscribe to
both and we will see you
in the next video, love you.
You've got this one?
We've got that one.
One of these,
one of these.
Cheers to SOG for the knife.
It can't be SOG.
It's got to be like "Standard
Operating Gear" or something.
Either way cheers for the knife.